welcome
to a new course on c plus plus and i'm
redoing this video so it's gonna look
way different than the rest i might redo
some of these if
they if i'm not happy with them but i
felt like the compiler one was way too
long so here you go i'm gonna
give you a quick rundown you just want
to be able to get your program compiling
that's the main thing for this tutorial
there's a lot of options for compilers
and basically what a compiler is
is something that reads the code that
you write and turns it
into an actual program that you can run
and it can also turn it into a library
or something for other programs to run
but that's a little more complicated
just think of it as
something that interprets the code you
write it turns it into a program you can
run
now one of the simplest ways to do this
on windows
is to download visual studio community
edition 2019 it's a free program
it's kind of large but you can get a c
plus workflow with
it and when you open it up
you'll get this and you can just do
something like
create a new project and then you can do
whatever you want here but let's do
empty project
make it really really simple and uh this
location i'm not happy with
repos and it doesn't matter what the
name is in my case so i'm just gonna hit
project one
and what this does is it sets you up
with the visual studio compiler
so somewhere in here we can look at it
and it'll tell us but it's basically
using the microsoft
visual studio compiler so we can always
look up more about that
let's do a new window and let's just
look up
compilers or c plus plus
close enough so you'll see a whole bunch
of them there's the
new one that's like the standard linux
one one of the things to know about
these is some
companies will make their own versions
of compilers just for their
specific use and they won't release them
to the public
there's main gw which is like a cross
platform compiler that works on windows
and stuff
and linux and mac and there's also clang
which is another one that's cross
platform we'll see and i've seen a bunch
not all of these are actually what i'm
looking for
i'm not seeing the msvc1 listed here
also i spelled compiler wrong so
there's the visual studio one so a lot
of
integration or uh development
environments which are
ides integrated development environment
like visual studio
will just come with one and up here you
can choose how you want it to build
want to build and debug or release now
real quick about debug and release
debug builds with some symbols to help
you walk through your code and maybe
find little peculiar errors that are
hard to discover
and 6x64 or 86
you know 32 bit is 86 64 is 64 bit
generally you just want to do 64 these
days because why not
but like visual studio gives you all
your project files over here and you can
click
this little show all files button to get
an actual structure
and and there we go so
when i hit run it's going to compile all
the code that i've written
but there is none i've written no code
so it's confused
and generally what you want to do is you
want to make a main so i'm going to do
it with the visual studio one and i'm
going to switch over and do it a
different way
just to show you the multiple options
but for your sake you just need to get
any of them working if you're using mac
you can look at xcode or you can do it
in the command line i'll show you how to
do it in the command line here
as well that will work with linux and
apple but first
let's uh let's for example show you how
you do it in an ide
now your ide will vary a little bit but
it's basically the same basically you
want to add a
a source file a dot cpp.c plus plus file
and call it main.cpp
and then here there's a standard bit of
code that every program needs and it's
the entry point so when you compile it
and set it up to run
it's where everything starts and that is
always a function
called int main and
i'll explain this real quick int is the
is what it returns it returns an integer
i'll talk a little bit more about that
later main is the name of the function
it's just what it looks for it has to be
named that
you can optionally put in a few things
here like um
hint arg c and
care star r and v
with some brackets it will also
find this version of the function and
you don't really need to worry about
these a whole lot right now but they are
basically
variables that you can pass into the
function when you start running it rxc
is a count of how many variables you
passed in there's always at least one
and it's the name of your software
so by default it does pass in
it'll be project one in this case so
there'll be at least one argument and
it's going to be the name project one
and arg v this is an array i'll talk
more about those later
but it's just all the different
arguments if you don't pass in anything
it's just going to be
only one of them and it's just going to
be it's basically a row of characters
think of it like a like text the
standard
c out hello world is what you usually
see and if you've seen any tutorials
before that's probably what they've done
and then you have to return some sort of
integer because it's expecting one for
this return type
and we could also say something like and
i'll explain
all these in a second you are
running
rv 0. arrays start at 0.
we'll put a new line here a new line
character so i'll walk through all this
code just to make sure
you at least understand the hello world
so i've explained most of this top part
but
in these uh little brackets here start
start and end the function
they're called a scope standard is a
name space which
i'll talk more about later as well but
basically
it's where something is found
[Music]
in in code somewhere else
or that's how you can think of it at
least and basically what it does is it
helps you not overlap because if you
have something else
that happens to be named c out um
it can be in a different name space and
it won't have trouble
so don't worry about that too much but
as you can see this
uh this is complaining it's got
underlined and that's the static
analysis
from visual studio so visual studio is
saying hey i don't recognize this it's
kind of helping us code that's the
really nice thing about ides is that
sort of help you walk through and
underline obvious errors
so you can actually right click on this
in visual studio and do quick actions
and refactoring
and it'll tell you what you need to do
you need to include iostream which is a
header file
it is a standard header file that allows
you to use c out
it also allows you to use cn which we'll
talk about more later
but for right now let's just do c out so
it's console out the other c
and it's consoling so we're basically
saying spit out to the console and then
you're going to have these two
alligator brackets
and then the text you want surrounded by
quotations and this slash n is a new
line
so it's going to spit out hello world
and then a new line to the console here
correct it a little bit and then
then it's going to do it again so this
just operates in order from top to
bottom next it's going to do another cl
and say
you are running semicolon and then we
can continue it you either end the line
with one of these or you continue it by
after your first quote putting these
alligator brackets again
and and something else you can put
variables in here
like this character array we could also
we could also put in here like argc
and it'll spit out that whatever this
integer number happens to be in our case
it should be 1
and then we can follow it up and just be
careful about your spacing
so it'd be like it should say
1 dot and then you are running
and then whatever the name of what we're
running this should basically evaluate
to project one
and then after all that a new line
character if it's just a single
character you can put it in single
quotes but if it is multiple characters
you have to put in double quotes
and so let's go ahead and run this now
by hitting our
local windows debugger and there we go
we got some
some output it says hello world one dot
you are running
and this is actually the full path but
at the end you'll see project1.exe
but it gives us our full path to where
it built our binary or
executable so there you go that's how
you do it with
an ide in general and as you add stuff
and add new things
you'll go further we'll talk about more
of that later is to get it
compiling so we're going to exit here
and i'll do it a different way that's
more specific to
command line so i'm actually going to
open a program called
cygwin you can go install this if you go
look for it you'll find a
website for it in a setup and you just
run the setup and
this is basically a linux like command
line
for windows and allows us to use the gcc
compiler that we were looking at a
moment ago so we can kind of get a linux
sample here but as you can see we only
got a command line we don't have an ide
in this case
so we have to make our own setup we do
have to type in things ourselves we have
to manually configure things some people
like this better
if you're following a linux tutorial
this is where it's going to start you
you could do most linux type tutorials
on windows with cygwin
there is also album engine wsl
so windows has recently started
integrating
linux in to windows with this windows
subsystem for linux
it is going to be very similar to what
you're seeing on cygwin
but it basically gives you like a ubuntu
linux
shell or command line so you can
optionally use
this for all your compiling needs
as you see it gives you some
instructions there's walkthroughs on
that if you want to get it going
sigwin's a little faster and easier to
get going so that's why
i've done that and i've just installed
in my root so now i can use
linux stuff like ls to list my files
and i can basically use other linux
commands so i'm going to do a couple
real quick to
give you an example of setting up a new
project so we're going to do a make
directory command
and let me just zoom this in a little
bit and i'm going to just call this
uh project one as well we're going to
make a directory called project one now
we hit ls we'll see we're in project one
and we can change directory into project
one
now this tutorial is not really about
these linux commands so i'm gonna breeze
over that
but some of these basic ones you'll need
to know if you're doing command line
stuff and in general if you're coding
you'll get used to them
so now that we're in a project it will
do another ls to see
any files and there's no files so we
want to make some files
the one we know we need for sure is a
main for
c plus plus so we're going to type a
command called touch
and main.cpp and what this does is the
file doesn't exist
it creates it but generally you want to
use the gcc compiler so
you want to make sure you have that or
in my case i think it's called g plus
plus you can do dash dash
version so if you type in this command
it'll tell you whether you have it or
not
and you can see i've got 10.2 here so if
you don't have it you'll need to install
it if you're on linux it's just like a
pseudo app yet
install g6g plus plus but which won't
work here and uh
and sigma and sigma you have to run the
setup again and go through and pick all
the c
plus plus stuff so hopefully you've done
that or i can figure that out
but basically i just want to show you
how to do this in command line so we
made our file
let's now edit our file if you have
visual studio code
installed sigmund will detect it and you
can just type code
and then your either your folder which
is this folder
which is just a dot or your file and you
can open the file with visual studio
code
and here we get the thing there's
another way to do it like you can do it
with them by typing in
provide fcpp and this gets you
the standard vim editor and which you
can also do vim stuff i don't want to
talk too much about
them because it's complicated i did a
tutorial on them go check that out
um but basically you just go into insert
mode
and then you start typing it in oh we
got to write
so there we go so that's essentially the
same as opening it
in visual studio code or any editor
and uh and operating it there but
starting out i would recommend not using
them right away or maybe you're
hardcore and you want to that's fine too
but uh
i guess the point is we can do all the
same stuff as we could do on visual
studio however we're using a
different uh compiler
that looks good close out of that and
now to compile this and turn it into a
program like
if you're using an ide usually just hit
the play button or the build button
and it essentially runs the camera in
the background on
command line you'll need to do something
like this you invoke your
program and then you feed it and
whatever it needs there's a lot of
different options we're just going to
leave it all default and just compile
this one thing
and uh now if we look at our stuff we
see we have an 8. executable
and that way we can get one called
main.exe
so either those will run the same right
now they're built the same and you run
it with this dot forward slash and the
name of the command line there we go we
got our stuff
the world people are running it tells us
what we're running
so hope you're able to get your compiler
running
and move on to the next tutorial thanks
for watching peace out